[Music]
hello
many argue the west is in decline and
some go further
arguing that the asian age has already
begun
but u.s politics is what dominates the
media
so in the west are we in denial do
americans and europeans cling to the
idea of western dominance
fearing the reality of a radically
different future
or is that story about the end of the
west a bit overdone
is it time to recognize that it's just
not that important who the us president
is or what american policy is in the
world
and should we be focusing on china and
its recently announced five-year plan
to triple gdp by 2035 or its civil
military strategy to use technological
advances to strengthen
its power economic and military
or is the us still really the most
influential country in the world
and in practice will it remain safe for
decades to come
well we're going to explore those issues
tonight as we get real
about global power my name is ron amita
i teach chinese politics and history at
oxford university
and i've got a fantastic panel for you
tonight to debate these
issues first of all michael pembroke who
is a former new south wales supreme
court judge
and author of a new book america in
retreat the decline of u.s leadership
from world war ii
to covert 19 then we have cindy you
who's a china reporter
and broadcast editor at the spectator
magazine as well as host of the
magazine's chinese whispers
podcast which i highly recommend then we
have melissa chan
who is an american broadcast journalist
reporter and collaborator with the
global reporting center
as well as a frequent presenter for dw
news asia
and she's worked with several news
outlets including abc news and al
jazeera
where she reported from uh with which
she reported from beijing uh
until 2012. and last very much not
least sir malcolm rivkin former
conservative mp
former secretary of state for defense
and foreign secretary
one of many prestigious cabinet
positions that he's held and
in fact he's one of only five members of
parliament to have served throughout the
whole
18 years of the governments of margaret
thatcher
and john major we're going to move to
the debate in just a minute or two but
first of all
i'd like to hear from each of my guests
tonight and get them to
just give us a couple of minutes of
thought on the big question
of whether we are clean to the idea of
western dominance
because we fear the reality of
a very radically different future
michael pembroke could i start with you
well thank you rana
i i do think most of us cling to the
idea of western dominance
and that's because we've become
accustomed to it and fear of the unknown
is a natural human phenomenon
on the other hand self-deception is easy
but realism requires courage i think
there's also a considerable degree of
western cultural
insecurity about asia and in particular
about china
the reality is that western dominance is
an historical aberration
in 1820 for example china and india
still represented half of the world's
gdp
it's often said that for 18 of the last
20 centuries
china's economy was the largest in the
world
today western economic dominance is
ebbing away it's largely a question of
scale
the e7 nations have surpassed the g7 in
contribution to global growth
the population of asia is four and a
half billion people
of which china represents merely a third
and china's population is
more than four times that of the united
states and more than double that of the
west
consisting of the uk western europe
north america of australia and new
zealand
and western credibility and respect have
also diminished
largely and unfortunately due to the
actions of the united states
following the end of the cold war in
1991
its hubris and unilateralism
significantly increased
in 2001 it commenced its suicidal wars
and in 2020 its dysfunction and
inequality
have been painfully apparent in the
meantime
china has achieved effective primacy
in the western pacific and probably in
most of eurasia
it all reminds me of george orwell who
once said
to see what is in front of one's nose
requires constant attention
thanks very much indeed michael very
concise and very much to the
point and on that question melissa could
we have your thoughts
well i think it depends on what you mean
by western
uh western tends to be a shorthand for
democracy and
if that's the case there's certainly
been a lot of angst over the last few
years about
the democracy's retreat in many places
around the world i mean the chipping
away of democratic norms in the us
attracting probably
uh the greatest amount of attention uh
although i'd be quick to point out that
some of the most
vibrant robust robust democracies are
in asia uh democracy such as taiwan
which has become a model of good
governance uh
in terms of how it's dealt with the
pandemic in 2020 but also i think of
south korea just a few years ago
hundreds of thousands of people took to
the streets of fantastic demonstration
of civil society and protest culture
and they brought down a president we
also of course have seen
months of protests in thailand and how
can we forget the perseverance
of the people of hong kong so if we're
talking about the west
in terms of the political system that
burst
uh in the west i would say that
democracy there are certainly a lot of
questions
uh about its robustness but in many ways
it remains
strong now if by the west you mean the
geopolitical order that is led by the
united states it gets a little trickier
and um i would say that people have been
slow on the uptake when it comes to
recognizing
a rising techno-authoritarian state that
is china a single-party state
led by a man who has designated himself
leader for life
a place that has the modernity of
beijing
and shanghai and its skyscrapers and its
capitalism
combined with the police state in
western china where we have seen
hundreds of detention centers and camps
that have by the un's own estimate held
some one million ethnic minorities
and the fact that the international
community doesn't seem to be able to
make
china budge on this or make china
do much in terms of xinjiang tibet hong
kong
so on um really does perhaps suggest
that we are
shifting from a rules-based
international order to a more
multi-polar world uh where there are
countries with uh
regional geopolitical spheres of
influence such as china and asia
thanks very much indeed uh melissa and
again very clearly uh clearly put
so on this question of whether the idea
of western dominance is something we are
clinging to
because we're worried about what
alternative might be rather than it
being a realistic view of where the
world is
and malcolm you've seen a tremendous
amount of world over the decades from
some very distinguished positions
what's your thought well i agree with
much of what my two colleagues have said
but
i think one has to start with a very
careful distinction are we talking about
absolute decline or are we talking about
relative decline
because they're very very different the
usual starting point is 1945 when the
united states
had something like 70 of global gdp
but of course the reason it had 70 was
because europe
was devastated by the second world war
and asia africa latin america
had not begun the transformation of
their economic and social
development today the united states and
europe
are infinitely richer than they were in
1945
their economic strength is much greater
their military capability is
dramatically
greater their cultural strength is very
very
important very very strong because uh
western culture rightly or wrongly still
is the culture in many respects
which has been adopted in latin america
in africa
and in much of asia including some of
our political values as has been
mentioned in the
in the thriving democracies like japan
uh taiwan
and south korea for example so when uh
xi jinping as chinese leader says these
are are not
anything other than european values
that's rubbish and that's rather like
saying you can only be a muslim if you
live in the middle east
because that's where islam began or
christianity began
for that matter final point i would make
is yes of course
in relative terms the united states
western europe
will not be as important aren't as
important today
and that will continue to change not
just as asia develops
but wait for latin america wait for
africa as well
the whole world is becoming more equal
it won't be entirely equal
but quite rightly and very attractively
all the nations of the world
are becoming modern economies with all
that that implies
and the final point i make is of course
china has a huge problem
if it seeks to if it seeks to dominate
both asia and the wider world
because it has a culture
and it has a language which are not
shared by
anyone else it doesn't have an ideology
like the old soviet union had
which appealed to many millions of
people in other parts of the world it
has nationalism
chinese nationalism which is so upset
all its neighbors
that they look to the united states for
security that's its asian neighbors
uh when issues once you start losing the
the actual um
support of the countries of your own
region and turn them into enemies
and then a question mark arises as to
whether that's a very wise strategy
thanks very much indeed uh malcolm and
let me turn
finally in this section to cindy cindy
you grew up in china but you've been
living in
the uk and therefore i guess the west
for quite some time you have a
pretty distinctive perspective on on
both do you think that we
are clinging to the idea of the west
being dominant because
we can't really wake up and smell the
baidu as they would call it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas